次 閻魔大王と悪魔様   そんな
次にそれについて はい
次に行きます 閻魔大王の行方ですね
のが亡くなっていますね
仏教では 罪人を審判する閻魔大王は成り立ちません
別に誰が審判しなくても
自分の心でしょうに 結果は出しますよ
成り立ちませんよ 仏教ではよくその話があるんですよ
それがもうバラモン教といったら
一般民間神話信仰から入ってるんですよ
神様をたてるバラモン教
ヒンドゥー教 現代ヒンドゥー教というんですけどね
の神話です 閻魔大王の話は
仏教も神話として道徳を教えるために使用しています
仏教は民謡などを借りるが
教えを借りることはありません
民話などは借ります 教えは借りません
ですから これも民話だから神話だから借りたんです
借りてもそれほど立場がない
本当に成り立ちませんよ
例えば 閻魔さんが地獄の行く人々を審判するんだったら
閻魔様はずーっと地獄にいなくちゃいかんでしょうに
ひどいそういう目になるでしょうに
だってずっといなくちゃあかんだから
これは成り立たないでしょうね
閻魔様は神様やとするならば
死ぬ人はみんないっぺん天界に行って
閻魔様に会って審判を受けて地獄に行かないでしょうに
それだったら もうどんな極悪人間の天界を垣間見る可能性あるでしょうに
なんか成り立ちません
しかし 神話で使ってますよ
一つ神話を紹介しますけど
それは仏典なんですよ
お釈迦様の経典から言います
あの 物語というふうなことはちゃんとあります
人が死ぬと死んだら 正義の味方たるすごい正しく政治をやっている閻魔様のところに
法を守っている閻魔様のところに行くんだと
言ったら 閻魔様がその人を見て
君 なんでこちらに来たんでしょうかとまず聞くんだと
そしたらもう知りませんよと
もうただ来たんだと もう死んだ人じゃなんだからね
だからこちらに来るところじゃないんだと
何かいいことをしたことはないんですかと
何一つ 一つだけでも良いこと
人間で 思い出せないんだと
私はね あの使者というか
天天使ですね 人間界に天使４人送ってるんだよと
あんた １番目の天使に会ったことはないんですか？と
そんなことは人間世界であるわけないでしょうと
あったならば もうその人に会っても私はいいことをするはずでしたと
あんたね 人がね 生命が生まれるのを見たことないのかと
それぞれいろんなところで
いろんな形で そうすると
この輪廻っていうのは大変なもんやと
業によって生まれるんやと
生まれたものは苦しんで生きてなくちゃいけないんだと
だったら正しく生きてなくちゃいけないんだと
それぐらいのことわからなかった
生まれた人を見たことないんですか？と
生まれた子供はいくらでも見たことはあるんだけど
そんなことは考えてなかったと
ああ そう では 2番目の天使に会ってない？に会ってないんだと
あのね 病気で苦しんでる人々を見たことはないんですかと
あれ 天使だよと 見たことあるんだと
その時考えてなかったのかと
人は病気になるんだよと苦しむんだよと
だから善行為するべきやと思うなかったね
そんな忘れちゃった そんなことはそんなこと思うわけないでしょと
その人答える では  3番目の天使に会ってない？会ってないと
あんたね 老いてる人を見たことないの？苦しんで体震えて歩けなくて
寝たきりになって いくらでもいたんだよ
その時考えなかったんですかね
私もこんな運命になるんだと
死ぬんだと だから徳をしなくちゃ済まなくちゃいけないんだと
思わなかったんだと では 4
番目の天使は見たことないんでしょうか？見てないんだと言ったら
あんた死んだ人を見てないんですかと
いくらでも見たんだよと
あれ 天使だよと 死ぬ人は言ってるんだよと
あんた方に あんた方もそんな運命になるんだよと
だから徳を積みなさい
悪をやめなさいという話をしてるんだよと
そんなこと考えなかったと
ああ そう ということで
閻魔様は  私にはどうすることもできません
助けることもできませんと
全てあなた自身で行った行為であると
悪業は それは自分自身で報いを受けるでしょうというってことで
悲しく顔を背込んだと
それは仏教は閻魔様の話はすごく優しく
仏教的に強引にするんですよ
別に閻魔様はいりませんよ
だから悪魔でも悪しき者でも何でもなく
とにかく助けを助けをしている人やというふうに
そこでも我々には人間に慈しみ
優しさ そのエピソードで教えている
それはただのエピソードですけどね
はい 次に行きます 地獄に落ちない人って誰ですか？と
このソーターパティという悟りの一番目
預流果というんですけども
漢字は出てこない 私のコンピューターで一番目の段階に達した人は決して地獄には落ちません
預流果になるということは
それほど難しくもないんですけど
言うとおりにやればね
それですごい自慢げに言うとおりにやらんぞというね
で 素直に私言うことを聞く
この方々はね まあ突然来て突然来るんだから
私は何者かもわからないんだからね
その場合 素直に聞くんですけどね
結構心は進んでますけど
で 預流果になった人は
この仏法僧には変わらない信頼があるし
因果法則は理解しているしね
大体その程度ですよ 煩悩から言えば
この疑心見とこの戒禁取と疑がないだけ
別に喜ぶ時 怒りとかありますよ
でも地獄には全く落ちない
因果法則を知っている人はね
仏法僧はもう絶対的正しいと知っている人はもう行かないんですよ
それは一般人にとっても
本当に仏法僧を信仰して
その通りに大事な気持ちでいれば
もう心は暗くならないんです
全然理解もしていないし
もう半信半疑でっていうのは
あまりこのエネルギーがわからないんですよ
本当にブッダに帰依しますという人
すごい心がすごい瞬時に明るくなって元気になるんです
この手段は この仏教の国で生まれている人々は
もうもう年がら年中しょっちゅう
毎日のようにもやっているんですよ
子供たちもゲームなんかいろいろやって
負け負けっぱなしになっちゃうと
時々ずる賢い子はそこをもう三経念じてやっちゃうと勝つんですよ
ずる賢いんですけどね
そんなのはもう遊びにでも使うというぐらいの
やっぱり遊びに使うって言っても
ちゃんと仏教法でないと効き目はないんですけどね
子供たちは結構聞きますよ
正直でしょうし まあちゃんと勉強もしているしね
他保証なし 他の人はね
心はいつ変わるかわかりませんでしょ
瞬間に心は悪い方に変わるんだからね
だからまあ 今日書いてないんですけど
例えば慈悲の瞑想とかね
強力 強力ですよ 一生いいことをしたことがない
何人かに私はこの間歇的にもう死にかけているんだから
何とかしてほしいと言われた時は
誰にでも慈悲の裏技を教えてあげる
とにかく裏技してでもその人はいいところに行かせるんです
本人は意識はそれほどない場合でも
耳元に念じてあげてくださいと
聞こえますよと 波動は受けますよと
で 大体自分の親やら親戚やらになってくると本気になりますから
その人もその時はね その時だけ
で 効くんですよ で 慈悲の念じちゃうと
この悪いエネルギーがなくなって
そちらにこのまあいい波動が返ってくる
そうすると その人が悪い妄想とか悪い幻覚があっても消えちゃうんですね
消えてくると心が晴れちゃうし
そこでこの慈悲の波動が移っちゃうんですね
それで明るい瞬間 明るい気持ちで亡くなるんです
本人にできれば一番効き目が強いんですけどね
だからごく普通にいつでも生きていければ幸せでありますよ
口癖にしておけばね 別に地獄には落ちません
三帰とかね それから五戒を守るとかね
三宝に帰依し 道徳を守り
徳を積む人は次回地獄には落ちません
これ次回の話なんですよ
永遠というわけじゃないんです
絶対落ちたくなければ
夜中に悟るしかないんです
より良い人間になろうと努力する人は安全でしょうと思いますね
人間に生まれてだらしない生き方をするんじゃなくて
もうちょこっといい人間になろうではないかという道徳気持ちあれば波動が変わらないでしょ
動物の次元に行かんでしょうに
それなのにもう生まれ変わったら犬になりたい
猫になりたいというバカもいるんだから
そう思えばなるんですよ
簡単に下は簡単にいきますよ
上はちょこっと努力しないと
はい 次 で 悪魔のお話 仏教ではマーラというんですね
煩悩に心の汚れ 煩悩に心の汚れにマーラと普通に言う
悪魔っていう意味ではなくて
仏教では普通にこの煩悩に言う言葉なんですよ
しかし 天界の上 6番目
パラニミタワサワッティというんですね
多聞十再生という日本語もあります
これ辞祭典なんですよ
かなりもう全部支配してやるぞというね
で  6番一番上の天界ですね
ワサワッティマーラという神がいて
おそらくそちらの人ではないでしょうかと
これははっきり経典もはっきりしないんです
だから私はおそらくこのワサワッティマーラという人格が出ますよ
サングートニカーにマーラさんユッタという一部もありますからね
かなりたくさん経典入ってます
そちらにも出てきますよ
もう人格として その人には名前がありますよ
ワサワッティマーラという
マーラだけといえば もうただ煩悩という意味なんです
だから人格の場合はマーラデーヴァプットーとかね
マーラという男の神が
男性の神がというふうに言うんですね
だから私が考えたのは
神だったらどこかにいなきゃあかんでしょうにね
だからおそらくこの 6番目の天界にいる誰かでしょうね
彼がブッダに邪魔をした
もう明確にブッダにはいろんな邪魔をしたんですね
解脱しようと励む修行者に迷惑かけるが
それも悟られるに 悟られる人に限ったものです
悪魔は邪魔しないんですよ
マーラさんは でお釈迦様にはものすごいもう攻撃したんですけど
お釈迦様はこんなことやっちゃうと
もう私のもう困ると まあ邪魔をするんで
どこかでまた可愛いんですよ
やっていることはもう本当に
腹が立ったり怒ったりいう気持ちは出てこないんですね
ニコッと笑っちゃいますね
マーラが来て お釈迦様にこういうこういうことをしましたとかね
やってることっていうのは
例えばこのお坊さんたち
瞑想していると この瞑想を進んでいくと
ヴィパッサナーの世界でもすごい恐怖感感じる時があるんで
それすごい上に行ったら
そういう時に限って周りでものすごい音を立てて誰かが歩くとかね
もういろんなことを見せたりして
でも修行者がもうしっかりしているんだから
簡単にもう攻撃できんですね
お前マーラでしょ？と言ったら
もうはい そうですということで
いく 嘘は言わない マーラは
何しに来たの？とかね
ある これスリランカのエピソードである
お坊さんがこの修行中で
そのお坊さんの趣味がありまして
お寺はきれいに掃除するんですね
お寺の土地はね だからこの菩提樹があって
仏塔があって そういうところはもうきれいに
この一欠片もゴミがないようにきちんとするんですね
そこはもう自分で修行しながら瞑想でもやってるんです
座って瞑想するよりは
もう掃除することが好きみたいです
趣味みたいにかなり心は統一するんですよ
マーラがこれ感じたんですね
この人はそろそろ悟る可能性あるんだと
瞑想している気配はないんだけど
これが怪しいと この毎日何回何回もやってるんです
誰にも言わないし 頼まないし
嫌な気持ちもしないで
すっごい尊い気持ちでもう掃除をする
これが怪しいと だから波動が心が変わるんだから
これ感じるんだからね
じゃあ邪魔してやるぞと言って
すごいボロボロ醜い汚い牛の形になって
お坊さんがこの綺麗にこの結構大きいんですね
場所も まあスリランカお寺っていうのは結構土地が大きいんだからね
で 終わったらいきなりどこかともなく
このボロボロ汚い醜いこの年取った牛が来て
この下痢なんですね ボロボロボロボロボロボロボロボとこのもう糞を出していくんですね
それも牛の糞が硬いんですけど
まあ硬くないのはもう
もう垂れるんですね これ出す
またあの美しい雰囲気がなくなるでしょうに
それ普通はもう踏んだったら簡単に捨てられます
これ難しいんですね お坊さんが何のこともなく
丁寧に全部またまたやと綺麗にするんです
疲れるしね これ時間かけて綺麗にするんですね
そしたらまたどこかからとあの牛が来て
またやる ３回ぐらいやったんですね ３
回目やったらこのお坊さん
あら この牛はどこから来るかもわからないし
とちょっと疑問に思ったんですね
心は嫌な気持ちにならなく
嫌な気持ちにさせようということで
それだけでもう瞑想は切れますからね
なんでこの牛やと言って
石で一足でもあげちゃって怒りが出てくるでしょうね
それでヴィパッサナーの世界だから
またガクンと落ちる もうまた初めからやり直さなくちゃいけないし
大変です あれ これおかしいと
これ牛にはなるはずがないんだと
そしたら牛に何のことはない
君 本当は牛じゃないでしょ？と言って言ったらそうですけど
誰ですかね 私は座って
いや あっ そうかそうか
よくお目にかかれてあれ
光栄やと お坊さんが 滅多に会うことできん方でしょうね
神の世界でも上だからね
大変光栄でございますと
あんた お釈迦様を見たことあるでしょう？と
すごくこのおいしい顔で
ああ まあさっき見たことあるんだけどと
こうやった態度でかいんですね
ただ お釈迦様ってどんな形でしょうかね
あんたにもすごい能力あるんだからね
ちょっと見せていただけませんか？と
実際のお釈迦様 仏像あってもね
これはお釈迦様の形じゃないんだからね
あ そんなちょろいやと言って
彼がまた変身してお釈迦様の形はこんなもんでしたねと見せたんですね
というと このお坊さんがこいつは悪人で
煩悩がありありで マーラで
そいつが作るブッダの姿もこんなに清々しいでしょうねと
本物のブッダってどういうことかと
あまりにも感動して悟ったんです
で マーラが何のことなく負けちゃったんです
そういうことでもうなんか仏教はもう笑っているんですよ
どこまで読んだんでした
だからこのみんなに迷惑をかけるわけじゃないんです
はい 他宗教の悪魔サタンとセイタンとも言いますけどね
は 罪を犯すように 神を否定するように誘惑するんですね
他宗教の場合は 神は完全に善だから
悪役は別に必要でしょうと
だからもう神を創った人間
人間創ったんだからね
完全性たる神やといっても
神が創った人間は完全じゃないでしょうね
悪いことばっかりしてるでしょうね
だったらしょうがない
物足らない では悪魔も作りましょうと
この昔の頭おかしい人々は創ったんですよ
サタンという概念は マーラ神はどちらかというと
人は徳を積むことに邪魔をしないのです
この悪い人じゃないんですよ
マーラは お寺作ったり
寄付をしたり もう戒律も全然邪魔しない
それを応援する 解脱だけは嫌なんですね
自分の支配範囲を脱するからだそうです
自分にはもう何ももういじることできなくなっちゃうんです
周波数が変わるんですね
これ嫌みたいですね なんか仲間欲しいみたいな感じですよ
出ていくなよと まあ親が子供が家出するともう反対するでしょ
そんな感じなんですね
家でいてほしいんだけど
家でいたら子供はダメになるんだから
だから家を出て苦しむくちゃいかないでしょうね
でも母親であったり 嫌なんですね
それが  そんなもんです
はい はい  そんなことで
これ悪魔さんです それはね
嫌な人じゃないんです
はい そこら辺で終了やと思います
はい 次のスライド出してください
では それで話は終了いたします
どうもありがとうございます
それで時間が延びました
えーと すみませんです
はい